and we are also going to be warning
against far okay this guy name them name
them name them you have to then why is
how is because we expose people you have
to expose the violators if you don't
expose the violators then this is not
CIA this is
wishiwashi do you know forget to check
out cy.com brothers and sisters one of
my most amazing clothing brands that I
wear owned by Muslims with the recent
boycott that's going on with many Brands
clothing L supporting Israel brother
sisters you guys know I've been
supporting sydney.com I've been wearing
their stuff long long time ago
alhamdulillah and I love their clothing
brother and sisters it's exactly what I
I like alah when it comes to Fitness
training jogging just general where when
I'm praying I don't need to worry about
my back showing buy it for your family
members your your uncles your brothers
your husbands whoever it is inshallah
brother and sisters buy it for yourself
inshah it's modest clothing wear Alum
brothers and sisters and dear friends
we're going to be doing some reaction
video to some claims that have been made
and we are also going to be warning
against she Faruk or are we we're going
to find that inshallah here's the video
let's get straight into inah and see
what we have to and we're also going to
be warning about ali da or Ali needs
dawa some like to call me that or you
know man of innovation we're going to
see we are being told by this individual
that you should be warned against he
that enough now he's crossed all line
yeah and me I'm already finished anyways
I'm in I'm in the saard so let's start
with in let's see what is his critique
ofman far and what's his critique of
working with us and being supportive in
our da let's find that here we go you
you test this any any any guy
any
any if you tell them
are I'm I follow the Quran and the go
to
You're it doesn't say that's a bad
example
what's his name when Alani came to the
ALB he says he told him I'm not I'm not
I never I'm not so the is very smart him
know you're not you
don't but your perfect so the first one
that we have is very clearly is that
basically say he AI but he doesn't move
like a Sal he doesn't act like AA and
what is the measurement of being a Sal
now this is very this is very important
yeah what makes one a salae we're going
to understand we're going to understand
soon what is the yard stick they have
and this let's see what they measuring
by so okay do it fit there no we're
going to find out inshah in a minute
okay so let's let's let's Carry On Let's
carry on for now yeah and I'm not I'm
not a so I got arrested in the in the
airport in um where is New Orleans Not
Orlando Orlando oh hey one second he got
arrested this typ type of people this
cult that they belong to these super
super copies that are they are free from
real true s by the way if there's anyone
that can say who's a Balan Cy who
doesn't go and do on everybody is
who doesn't look for the mistakes who
doesn't assume the worst in the
Believers who when he has a problem he
privately messages and contacts and
tries to Cy let me tell you
something I see more in than you sh Abu
Abu all of you put together you cannot
be a sopy you guys are a cult but let's
car on this man got arrested you are
known to arrest people you guys are
known to call the feds and the police
not on illegal stuff yes you are known
of course you have to like if I know
that somebody I've had this who came
attack me that if I hear somebody who's
going to go and do a attack on
non-muslims innocent people walking past
I will brother I will call the Feds all
day every day call me a snage whatever
you want to call my religion calls me to
let know that this person is going to
cause more damage in the name of my
religion I will call him to the Feds all
day every day all day every day so I
know that I'm not talking about that I'm
talking about these guys who they deem
someone to not from that manh they Gras
real snitches yes okay these group of
individuals that's what they attend to
do and this guy got arrested as well
taste your own medicine yeah let's carry
on and so the Subhan Allah he told me
told me because you're not clarifying
your stance for clarify say this guy
this name them name them name them you
have to then why is how is because we
expose people you have to expose the
violators if you don't expose the
violators then this is not this is
wishiwashi you know okay this is true
the statement is true but it's coming
from place of battle like when Ali came
was I
when it came the okay he
said I forgot the rest but you saying
basically what you're saying is H but
the way you're going about is Battle so
it is H that Allah says tells us in the
Quran Let There rise among you a group
of people who will enjoy good enough for
evil but you are misapplying it so he's
having to go by saying hold on a second
he's saying um you the fact that now
he's saying that he's followers that
people that follow him now can you
imagine got he's busy already like I
know how busy he is Subhan Allah yeah
that there was one thing that I um asked
the she he was going to get do something
but I realized the she is so busy I
assume the best because I know how it is
to be a public figure being invited it's
overwhelming do you get it alhamdulillah
so may Allah make it easy for him for
him but now he's having a by saying you
got
this type following you now you're to
blame for because they're following you
you need to make it clear anyway let's
carry on then I want to categorizes with
regards to first of all and his
interview with IM was a total mess his
debates against non-muslims of course
like I told you it's very questionable
it shouldn't be like that so this is a
part where I didn't react to this in the
beginning he's saying that um his da is
more like I think he was saying ego
argumentative Etc now fin enough we
understand with FIS I've fallen for this
as well we're in the daa these are
shortcomings you can advise your brother
I understand why he's saying this
becomes an ego thing we're trying to
prove them wrong it seems as if even
myself I'm in the da it comes across
sometimes in the da it's like we're
trying to win an argument it's like
we're not doing daa but we're trying to
but you need to understand when you're
dealing with enemies of Islam now
because you haven't done da
MRIs yes okay because you've never done
I would say da in the sense probably um
you know where we're dealing with
enemies of Islam it's easy for you to
talk my friend it's easy for you to talk
so I know where is coming from and I
know we can sometimes fall into that
where it comes across as if we just
debating or doing daah to win and it
seems like that and what he's saying is
true what far is saying true when it's h
you have to tell him it's true it
shouldn't be like da is not do in an ego
it's not for me it's not so Al can be
amazing debat oh he look how he destroys
people I'm not there to destroy people
I'm there to guide people so far however
yes sometimes we get caught up and it
can come across like that so I
understand and just because I dislike
him for the sake of Allah this firest
guy I'm not going to come and take away
everything no what he's saying here is
true but now you are claiming as if does
that on purpose or it's like you don't
know you don't know it's it comes across
like that yeah you got hostile people
coming doing this Etc and all you guys
do is attack the people in the da so I
know where is coming I assume the best
in him and then he praised also what's
his
name Allah we're finished praise me he's
with him and he's a brother and he
smiles and laughs with him and and you
claim to be and and all that I don't
know if he claims to be people look at
you as a you don't praise these people
don't stand with these people was a
fatan we know this he's a liar he's a
fan he calls for I don't understand how
this this is something that is light on
your heart okay good so me Ali da I
called to
to B to Innovation look I don't take
this guy's word seriously but just a
proef point can you please tell me one
single Innovation I've called for just
one one one just tell me one sing not
two three four 5 6 seven eight please
please I'm asking a very simple question
I want to react to this please can you
tell me one Innovation that I have
called for but the thing is with you
your deem what you deem to be Innovation
because you come from a person no no
knowledge I'm alen Da no problem when I
say something it's like alen da no
problem you're a person knowled
knowledge when you talk about Innovation
what Innovation are you talking about
bro who who who do you de to be
innovators this is your problem who is
innovators and what is innovation to you
that is the problem because you have I'm
so sorry and you seem like you have
knowledge you don't have knowledge
you've got white beard you have no
knowledge I'm so sorry so the fact that
you accusing myself okay can you please
tell me what innovation did I called for
let's carry on Ma jealousy there's no
jealousy on religion here let me show
you this this clip so you understand
fighting over footage Etc very very
important because the biggest F that we
have now is that
oh I need get this foot understandable
we
understand is not copyrighted anybody
can use it so you can sense that they're
friends they're very good with each
other and you know they're laughing and
whatnot for everybody else watching I do
want to say now can you imagine a Muslim
he is Disturbed to see one brother in
the da being kind and soft with another
you cannot make this stuff up bro please
he's watching and he's comfortable he's
upset that far is showing love now what
does that remind me of oh yeah in the
Quran Ayah where Allah subhana the one
who created the heavens and the Earth
telling us as Believers that you should
be soft towards one another you should
be good towards one another the the
blood of the Muslim is more sacred than
the ca like Allah is saying be soft
towards the Muslims and be harsh towards
the enemies of Islam but who actually
does it the opposite way where they are
soft to the enemies of Islam and Ally
with the enemies of Islam and harsh
towards the Believers who takes this ay
and does it the opposite way oh yeah you
guys do thank you very much let's carry
on inshah we need unity in the scene we
need unity in the scene with the people
of H we don't need unity in the scene
with with people of and Liars we have to
disassociate from them yes we need to be
uniting with the people of is true what
he's saying
again is
saying but the concept is B he's
basically saying who the question I'm
asking is this who do you deem to we
people of H Abu the biggest backbiting
slandering he's at the Flesh of so many
scholars you can't even brother I think
on all his Good Deeds are going to go to
people back bited and I think he's going
to have no good deeds left yes and he's
going to carry the sins of the people
back backit Subhan Allah you and us to
be these are the people a handful of
five six people 20 people these are and
the rest are
misguided it reminds me of one brother
said to me that there was they were they
were they were doing
and the other one said to the other one
he said you see all these he said all of
these people he said all them aref the
other guy subh all of them are going
Hell Fire except us he said no I think
he said I'm going to go join them and he
saying what you're saying is Battle
you're nons all of these people are
misguided Subhan Allah why because he
deems who is to be inator let's carry on
many brothers don't realize but me and
our brother Ali we've spoken many times
offline you know yeah if I make a
mistake Ali reaches out to me he reminds
me if he makes a mistake I reach out to
him if two brothers have issues we reach
out to them just because we're not
making drama I'm jealous now because I
reached out to you listen to me why I
don't get the same privilege as that was
nice to you too why gets that privilege
when he gives you you accept it and you
listen to him and then when gives you
you ignore me yeah I mean uh why does he
ignore you because you have a reputation
brother you have a reputation you know
it's this this kind of jealousy which
you said it's actually permissible
jealousy it's like what you want what
she man is doing to for myself you want
the same this is good kind of jealous
even blame with the jealousy yes okay
and this is the jealousy that we have
with you guys okay Subhan Allah the love
that you show the enemies of Islam and
allies the the people that you work with
ETA we are jealous that you don't treat
us like that far I'm jealous that you
don't have that treatment of us why are
you not like the way you're jealous with
far how he is with me yes and not with
you because ask yourself a question what
are you causing for him to like and now
I'm jealous because we have done nothing
nothing for you guys to treat us like
that who are you you're not even a
person of knowledge you're not even
allowed to call myself a person of
innovation this is Haram this is not
your job okay it is not your job you
cannot deem people to innovate is based
on your conditions let's carry on
doesn't mean we don't give each
other but behind the scenes and when you
want good for somebody when you want
good for someone and it's behind the
scenes
okay so you know Al he's way past behind
the scenes we all know
this and the guy he calls he calls for
his friends with what's his name mamed
and they go and they seek knowledge or
they seek fwa from from bani yeah
moritan guy he talks about there is no
muslim state in one of his videos he
said that yeah not to mention the
slandering he does against some of the
brothers in the da scene lies lies pure
lies you know so about some lies the
prophet said the believer is anything
but a liar I it's an open challenge
please tell me one lie I've made against
you that is a lie it's a lie a slander
please tell me bring me evidence and
then you about brother his knowledge let
me tell brother if listen if we took
your whole crew your super copies every
single one of you guys together I don't
think you reach the knowledge of okay
just because you don't take from him
just because you give him a label
because you you think I'm going to now
come and follow you who are you bro who
are you just because an Alim a a Al
somebody who is an Alim and I'm going to
come and put a question mark on him
because of people like you slers
backbiters who actually genuine standard
backbiters you guys have back bit so
many people I cannot even count my hand
so please bring your evidence
look bring your evidence if you're
truthful what sland have I done which
lie have I done do you not go and talk
about the boycott you mock the boycott
you talk tell us not the boycott brother
you work for the government Bro you've
said it yourself bro you're on the
payroll don't come and talk to me about
anything you're on the payroll a so
don't come and see to me on lying about
anything bro when the pal being mass and
Slaughter don't come to me and talk talk
to me about that anyways we're nearly
done in but Jake fans or Daniel fans
what do they do how they do they
interact with it or do they completely
ignore it uh you know I'm going to
caveat this by saying I haven't read
what's going on between them so I don't
want to give an opinion without being
well informed I mean my life is just
insanely busy um obviously I know both
of them personally and they're both good
brothers mallah and we respect the good
that they're doing for the umah um Jake
they're good brothers and he respects
what they're doing for the um Daniel you
respect what he's doing for the um is
doing calamities after calamities he's a
disease to the um so guys I'm going to
wrap up on this aldah far may Allah
bless and preserve his da he's the only
that I have seen who calls for Unity
Unity upon H not B he is not someone
he's a true salafy why because a true
salafy somebody who the Sala they would
say they would make good assumptions for
their brothers not based on a specific
cult or a group that I deem these are my
conditions who made this conditions we
made this condition we're like a coat we
have this set of Scholars okay and we
deem this to be Innovation perfect so
now anyone that does meet meet these
criteria is you're a j you my friend
you're a j so if there's anyone that I
can come and say well I'll be honest
with you
AB far
tah and there's many I cannot think top
of my head W if there is anyone that are
true genuine balanc copies are these
people that I can vouch for why and I'm
nobody because they when they give the
they look and see this this brother am I
calling Innovation do I tell people to
go grave worship do I tell people to go
and do this and that Etc cleck never
never and anytime we do a mistake our
brothers advise us privately we're open
to advice they show us love when they've
come W the experience I've had with them
they have done nothing but show us love
and this is not a criteria but I'm
saying that they act on the AY when
Allah tells them to be soft with the
Believers and they do this so all I'm
going to say is may Allah bless da and
people like him throwing mother him it
further proves his da alhamdulillah is a
good da that is calling to Islam of
course like I said before it's an advice
to myself sometimes we're in the debates
and discussions Etc we get it you know
ego can get in the way it happens to me
and we're human beings other than that
to come and act like if there's anyone
that is a disease and we're talking
about daniu and J they do fantastic work
for the um more than you can ever do in
your life and of course they're not
perfect and if any of them cross the
lines of calling to Absolute misguidance
of sh or this that they should be
publicly warned against that's all I
will say in till next time Asam